>> Gillian: CHARLES, STAY SAFE
AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR REPORTING
REPORTING.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN IS FACING
PRESSURE TO KEEP THE
NATIONAL GUARD AWAY FROM THE
U.S. SOUTHERN BORDER.
THE LARGEST LATINO ADVOCACY
GROUP, URGING THE PRESIDENT TO
STOP STATES FROM SENDING THEIR
OWN LAW ENFORCEMENT TROOPS TO
TACKLE THE BORDER CRISIS SAYING
"WE TOLD THE PRESIDENT IN NO
UNCERTAIN TERMS, THIS IS AN
INTERACTION BETWEEN REBELLIOUS
STATES THAT MUST BE STOPPED."
A DOZEN STATES HAVE DEPLOYED
TROOPS TO CONFRONT THE SURGE OF
MIGRANTS, CRITICS SAY IT LEFT
THEM NO OTHER CHOICE.
LISTEN.
>> THIS ADMINISTRATION CANNOT
PRETEND TO BE SERIOUS ABOUT THE
CRISIS AT THE BORDER IF THEY
REFUSED TO SECURE OUR BORDER!
THAT MEANS ENFORCING OUR BORDER
POLICIES, IT ALSO MEANS AND
DAILY POLICIES THAT ARE TAKING
PEOPLE HERE IN THE FIRST PLACE.
I’M GLAD TO SEE THERE ARE
GOVERNORS BECAUSE THEY NEED TO.
THEY NEED TO PROTECT AND DEFEND
THEIR STATE!
>> MARK BARRON OF HD
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF ARIZONA
JOINS US NOW.
THIS IS PITTING
PRESIDENT BIDEN’S EXECUTIVE
PREROGATIVE AGAINST THE STATES
PREROGATIVE TO PROTECT INTEREST.
WHO DO YOU SEE COMING OUT ON TOP
HERE ULTIMATELY?
>> I THINK THE FIRST THING WE
NEED TO START WITH IS WHAT DOES
THE CONSTITUTION SAY?
>> Gillian: IT SOUNDS LIKE A
REASONABLE PLACE TO START.
[>> THANK YOU.
LOOK, AT THE END OF THE DAY,
THESE STATES HAVE THE RIGHT,
THEY HAVE THE RIGHT TO HAVE
HISTORICALLY PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY, THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
ARE ADVOCATING THE
RESPONSIBILITY, INCENTIVIZING
PEOPLE.
PEOPLE TRY TO CROSS THE BORDER
ILLEGALLY, WE KNOW THERE ARE
1.2 MILLION PEOPLE REFUSING TO
DEPORT.
THAT MEANS CRIMINALS ARE BEING
RELEASED INTO THE COMMUNITY.
THE REALITY IS, THIS IS THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION’S JOB AND
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WORRIES
ME SO MUCH, ONE OF OUR LAWSUITS,
EMAILS HAVE COME OUT THAT DURING
BLACK HISTORY MONTH ACTIVISTS
SAID THE WHITE HOUSE, URGING
THEM TO STOP IT AND THEY DID.
THEY’RE NOT LISTENING TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT, THEY’RE
LISTENING TO ACTIVISTS.
THIS IS A BAD SIGN THAT THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WILL CAVE
TO THE FAR LEFT WING OF THE
PARTY AND THAT WILL RESULT IN
PEOPLE GETTING HURT.
SPEED TO TAKE A LOOK AT THIS,
33% OF RESPONDENTS INCLUDE THE
HANDLING OF THE SOUTHERN BORDER,
51% DISAPPROVE.
THIS ISN’T ISSUE THAT HAS DOGGED
HIM FROM DAY ONE.
THE VICE PRESIDENT HAS TRAVELED
TO THE REGION, TRAVELED TO THE
REGION, TRAVEL TO THE NORTHERN
TRIANGLE, HAVE YOU SEEN ANY
SIGNS FROM ANYONE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT THE FORWARD
MAY BE CLEARER?
THINGS MAY IMPROVE?
>> BY ANY OBJECTIVE STANDARD,
THE SPIKE IN FENTANYL, DECREASED
DRUG PRICES, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS EMPOWERED THE
CARTELS, THEY MADE OUR
COMMUNITIES MORE DANGEROUS BY
ALLOWING THEM INTO OUR
COMMUNITIES.
IT’S ONLY GOING TO GET WORSE.
I DON’T LOOK AT THOSE, BUT WHAT
I DO CARE ABOUT IS PROTECTING
TAXPAYERS.
THERE IS GOING TO BE PHYSICAL
COST ASSOCIATED ADD HUMAN
TRAGEDY ASSOCIATED, WHETHER
THAT’S THE INCREASE IN OVERDOSE
DEATHS, DRUG DEPENDENCY, WHETHER
IT’S GOD FORBID ONE OF THESE
CRIMINALS BEING RELEASED.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS
ADVOCATED THEIR RESPONSIBILITY.
>> WE’VE ALSO LEARNED THAT THE
WHITE HOUSE, THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL, THEY ARE
HONORING THE POSSIBILITY OF
TAKING MULTIPLE OTHER STATES TO
COURT OVER THESE NEW ELECTION
LAWS.
IT COULD LIKELY INCLUDE YOUR
STATES.
WE WANT TO BRING THIS UP FOR
VIEWERS.
YOU PROMISE TO FIGHT ANY LEGAL
CHALLENGE.
YOU SAID ARIZONA WILL NOT SIT
BACK, REFUSE TO UPHOLD WALLS OR
COMMANDEER OUR STATE SOVEREIGNTY
SOVEREIGNTY.
IT’S A BOLD PROMISE THERE.
ARE YOU CONFIDENT YOU WILL
PREVAIL IN A COURT OF LAW?
>> IF YOU LOOK AT THE CASE I
JUST ARGUED, IT’S CLEAR THE
COURTS ARE NOT IN THE MOOD FOR
THIS NONSENSE.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE HYPOCRISY OF
THE LEFT, NEW YORK, NEW JERSEY,
THE LIST GOES ON AND ON, WE
OFFER A PLETHORA OF OPTIONS.
IF THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
WANTS TO TAKE OUR STATE TO
COURT, I WILL FIGHT THEM.
TO QUOTE AL DAVIS.
>> DOES IT GO TO ARIZONA, UPPING
THE ANTE FOR YOU, MAKING THE BAR
HIGHER?
>> IT WILL MAKE IT MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT FOR DOJ TO PROCEED
WITH THESE PUBLICITY STUNTS AND
MAKE NO MISTAKE, THAT IS WHAT
THEY ARE.
THEY’RE TRYING TO APPEASE THE
FAR LEFT OF THE PARTY AND THEIR
SHREDDING THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE.
I WORKED THERE, THE IDEA THAT
THEY WILL GO INTO RED STATES
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO MICROMANAGE
IS REALLY NOT ONLY THE
CONSTITUTION, BUT IT EXPOSES HOW
POLITICAL THIS IS.
WE KNOW THERE ARE WHOLE HOST OF
STATES WITH WAY MORE
RESTRICTIONS THAT ARIZONA HAS.
SHAME ON THE DOJ AND HE BIDED
ADMINISTRATION FOR CAVING TO